We are continuing to uncover more
secrets about Rihanna's record-breaking
Super Bowl halftime show you may not
know Hamish Hamilton but you know his
work he has directed the last 14 Super
Bowl halftime shows but he's never done
anything like what we saw on Sunday he
filled me in on how they pulled off
Rihanna's big moment
[Music]
[Applause]
at what point are you guys like wow
she's pregnant but how do you hide that
from the world she was very careful
about who knew and we only knew really
the very very kind of latest stages
there were so many secrets and so many
Mysteries that had to be catching
Hamish has established himself as being
music's MVP for dropping live pregnancy
Bombshells in 2011 he also captured
queen bee's Blue Ivy bump at the VMAs
apparently I am now the go-to guy for
pregnancy reveals it kind of brings a
tear to your eyes
but Rihanna's moment came with an extra
layer of stress oh you know just
suspending a pregnant woman with a fear
of heights 60 feet in the air
we practiced it in baby steps you know
first it was 10 feet then it was 20 then
it was 30. I'm sure many times during
the process she was like really really
what I said after this she just I think
delivered the Super Bowl of all time and
now Rihanna and ASAP Rocky are gearing
up to deliver a second baby after
debuting their nine-month-old son on the
cover of British phone
the cover shot was taken around two
months ago in December on Instagram Riri
revealed she didn't know she was
pregnant yet quote how crazy both of my
babies were in these photos and mommy
had no clue
[Music]